which I grew Tony again we'll do a demo
tomorrow why does Elmo get up I'm back
you know Platinum we all know why
hermanos let them on Mira my hermano
caravans of migrants and refugees are
coming from Central America because of
poverty and violence but climate change
is also playing a big role now the new
climate change the coordinates climate
change the climate change climate
emergency climate change today and it
came with a dire warning o sufferers
were the main places they're fleeing
from and it's experiencing a water
crisis
[Music]
95% of the surface water in the country
is undrinkable
[Music]
bueno el salvador bivy muna problematic
a gravure que estamos amman asado por el
estor heed Rico Iona history Nikita Teva
del agua en gusta Yom Kippur dicen que
hacen agua cuando era nationalistic
Sporting News revoir in the summer of
2018 droughts and what's known as
Central America's dry corridor that's
Guatemala Honduras Nicaragua and El
Salvador have been projected to leave up
to two million people hungry pasado when
sakaba Myung
Lauren do e or a syllable factor porque
la Oviedo Mucha gente está diciendo la
guaa que la Ciccia acido differencial a
lo largo del país a lejano sin medio de
vida a muchas de la población dural a
primer o MP a sangha immigrant Erna
mente hacer la capital y luego a cinema
Graziano sell devices Mexico Central
America could see up to 3.9 million
climate refugees in the next 30 years
and around the world it's expected that
just over 143 million people will be
displaced by climate change by 2050 in
El Salvador it's not just droughts that
contribute to lack of water for many the
taps are also running dry because of the
threat of privatization of what little
drinkable water is left I traditional
corporate Eva case tantras Laura cursos
naturally de Latin America ek donde
quiero que I Enrico so para ser explore
tal esta empresa Banga llegar con Falcon
hombre the right wing in the country is
trying to introduce a comprehensive
water law that will include members of
the business sector on their governing
board
[Music]
before it becomes privatized no
sovereign its most vulnerable
communities could lose out creo que la
extraction el explotation yella kappa
ramm en todo lo wrecker so naturally por
supuesto que onda principal me indeed
around 600,000 people in El Salvador
have no access to drinking water that's
around 10 percent of the country's
population under Bill Chavez Mejia is
one of them she lives a new route an
apartment in what's considered part of
El Salvador's dry corridor I bespoke a M
of pasado estado tiene la vez es
solamente L poquito para tomar loan amok
en lo más importante Verano morir sur la
ser necesitamos UN proyecto de agua
puede que lo Hobbit esse donde los ninos
pueden tener sohil amento a
the aussie oliver de poder en que estar
agenda comment' ABN Banali Olimpico CIA
gua para que el nino tommy creo que no
hay agua para la VAR le Tampa algo que
una fruit attack elevator yah ESO is
Oprah Vienna bastante pull our infirmary
la población mas por que no tiene SSO
agua es la paga austell tre siento por
ciento mas c ba can't element a las
chicas en del agua por que
yeah cuando se termina en una simeon
topo ya los toca comprare la la compra
mujeres en cuenta de la gloire ow
more than $3 a barrel of water cost more
than half of a row Salvadorans earn in a
day yeah you know effect a Co Clara en
los hombres de las mujeres los ninos ela
Nina's porque solo mujeres los Ninio de
la niñas la que su pone en el trabajo
for Sol de Erica really lava on top of
the burden of retrieving water of
saboteurs one of the most dangerous
countries in the world for women
in 2017 one woman was murdered every 18
hours tambien sabemos de que mucho a co
so hemos tenido el caso de una mujer
Tierra defense hora de un territorio a
vile Aramis weeha
le monde are una de seer Cana Pandya
tell a vo La Mancha su era por el
trabajo assume all Latin America
continues to be the most dangerous
region for environmental activism in
2017 the area accounted for 60% of all
environmental activists killed hemos
tenido hombres y mujeres de maurienne o
a et nosotros todavia subtree - no uncie
declare offical pero croakin centromeric
i principal maintain guatemala honduras
se estaba viendo una situación bastante
cruelly Cano defensores hasta donde
puede llegar el riesgo creo que es in
men so porque en algunos pices i
persecution política en otro hanga vido
persecution e criminalization I'm Millie
de hombres también y ciento de mujeres
que estan defend en Doan primarily me a
que la Somoza meant a mooring in muchas
veces sus criminis son a nqv air tows
poor delinquency upon mu
[Music]
despite the challenges of defending
water there have been some environmental
winds in 2017
now several became the only country in
the world to ban mining the laminaria an
Veneto contaminant ad agua a Qatari
empleos Ellicott our medio de vida
totales che sono que la gente tanea
historico mentaiko moola lava culture
Adaeze subsistence que diferentes
corporaciones pone en los ojos en el
salvador para la exploitation en un país
de Benton Kahlo Metro cuadrado ston
Chiquito la exploitation a laminaria
Metallica Ecco fact an obvious Acedo
liitle para nuestra Fuente de agua toes
en la población Salvadoran hace organiza
y resist a poor madidi Sano's
yeti seona un cambio de Modelo en el
tema de rooy beer literalmente la manera
lex flotation de laminaria metallica in
2015 the local government stood up to
coca-cola and stopped them from digging
wells in a Salvadoran town of the Hoppa
but the fight to protect the environment
and natural resources in the country is
far from over
[Music]
hey guys thanks for watching don't
forget to Like share and subscribe
what should we cover next please let us
know in comments below and watch this
video on environmental activists about
the gussets